I might tussle the top lawyer I'll fight
for you and I'll win
I read all it's one of our best
commercials I'm honestly proud it's so
good
who makes that crap I know they suck I
hope they die we should find him and
kill him
whoa Sam do be fine Tim Kremlin Kremlin
advertising fellas it took a lot of
balls coming in here like this - stomach
is upsetting will she come rub his belly
why don't you do he wants you I got sick
going nuts I've got to go my friend
can't prove monster of this belly
old diet pills these things are basic
with speed you think it's safe to take
some of those I don't know
[Music]
Jack you're known all over town is the
guy with a dick in his mouth it's not
just sticks no they'll beam boobs yes
team two I have to I've seen a butt
pooping boobs yeah yeah no it's not sexy
that reactions gonna sell a lot of hot
tubs pull the plug on your ass do it
life support you idiot you're my best
friend here medicine
you guys don't drink and each other off
you see she is everywhere Leah yeah Leah
if we were a jerk each other off the
beaches everywhere